before Rihanna turned heads at the Met
Gala on Monday night in New York City it
was ASAP Rocky who got people talking
using a Fan's face to help him hop over
a barricade at the Carlisle Hotel
nothing is off limits as you will see in
a moment
let's rewind
leading up to Fashion's big night the
rapper appeared to push past a group of
people and jump over a barrier outside
of the hotel
[Applause]
yeah zoom in now pause that's Rocky hand
on fans face
well that footage went viral and the fan
who space Rocky palmed revealed herself
on Tick Tock to be 21 year old Madeleine
llanis from Long Island New York
someone's tapping my shoulder and I turn
around and I like I see that it's ASAP
Rocky but my brain isn't comprehending
another day ASAP Rocky and he's like
sweetheart I need to get through and I
went no and then he just kind of like
starts shoving he's right here and then
suddenly his hand is literally on my
face and he hops over and he kind of
like he turns back around and he's like
thank you
like anybody else you just take it in
stride you know and keep going Madeline
later
Excel earlier
in Stars outfits up close and said she
wasn't injured from the incident adding
that after it happened she was just a
little confused but laughed about it for
a while
[Applause]
immediately after the whole thing went
down Madeline shared this selfie on
Twitter writing ASAP Rocky just
literally jumped over me and Rocky he
replied tweeting LOL my fault sweetheart
he said sweetheart and he got through
like five times and we're all like what
the well Rocky made it to the met
with Riri by his side give us some
insight to this look there's a piece
called Lagerfeld you know this is just
tradition to him and I just wanted to
pay homage the right way a little bit of
kittens you know what's this lipstick
over here but that's from my lady hey
how's the little man doing growing big
beautiful happy baby thank you for
asking and congratulations oh baby never
do thank you the singer is pregnant with
their second child and stunned on the
carpet in a white Valentino gown that
showed off her growing baby bump how is
the second pregnancy how are they
different from the first one
um just everything all of my
no Cravings tons of nausea
everything's different but I'm enjoying
it I'm enjoying it I feel good I feel
energetic
[Music]
thank you